Tasha is nine months old home is the 50
square meter apartment in Warsaw that
her mother Marta tamala bought 10 years
ago everything seemed to be okay until
january fifteenth when switzerland
removed the cat pegging its currency the
franc to the euro Brynja stovall lock
the exchange rate of the swiss franc has
me worried well my mortgage were in
[ __ ] then I could sleep peacefully at
night and wouldn't constantly be
thinking about the price of the Frank
Cuccia almost 600,000 poles are paying
back loans notated in swiss francs such
loans used to be easier to get than
loans in slot II people were able to
burrow at relatively low interest rates
with very little collateral required
Tron kovitch people who borrowed francs
are now in a difficult situation but
real estate in Poland has lost value in
recent years and now the size of the
loan measured in the money these people
earned has suddenly increased many Poles
face this problem for example a borovsky
family after long consideration they
bought an apartment in Warsaw six years
ago their monthly mortgage payments have
just shot up to six hundred and fifty
euros 130 more than two weeks ago now
they'll have to decide what they can do
to tighten their belts notice sure it's
done maybe I'm not them too so I'm
constantly thinking about what we can do
without mortgage me that is nobody
amiable that as I guess we'll be cutting
back on what we adults spend in Maple of
the pod Omni other designee and we
certainly don't want to shortchange our
children that are sitting on the
fictional she born on bond without any
custom duty
those who borrowed in a foreign currency
knew there was a risk but no one knew
how big that risk was it was a game of
luck like in a casino now they are
scrambling to meet their payments Marta
tamala was 21 years old when she took
out her alone today she regrets
listening to her bank advisor she
borrowed Frank's worth fifty thousand
euros from the bank the loan will now
cost her 60,000 due to currency
fluctuations Dublin senior scrubbers
adopted English car I love this
apartment it's the apartment for us if
there's a real neat thing is I never
thought life would hit us so brutally I
never expected this loan to create so
much worry for us Oh sarcastica critical
but her problems have just begun Marta
will be repaying her loan for the next
25 years